let's talk a little bit about coffee Pat
are you still caffeinating is that still
happening at this point I'm gonna have
to show the audience oh you have look at
this I mean this is heavy duty right and
that's metal isn't it yeah that doesn't
try to learn them any meat at will
illuminate McDonald yeah doesn't
transfer a metallic taste into your
coffee maybe it does but maybe I like
the touch of metallic taste yeah some
people add milk some people add sugar
being vegan you're opting for a little
metal right metal is vegan right I mean
it's you can eat metal absolutely it's
not an animal problem animal yeah okay
listen here's the point though we have
these two coffee roasts and we're going
to start giving them away as of today
okay we have the starting over here
progressive wake-up call this is an
espresso coffee roasts good for all
sorts of espresso machines and over here
we also have freedom of the press coffee
roasts this is great for percolators
drip coffee applications chemex french
press etc what's your preferred drip
coffee application like what are you
using to make the coffee I honestly
don't even know I mean I use a Keurig I
put those little pods in there Oh
sometimes I get the plastic ones but
also you can use you can use this
regular coffee and pour that in as well
don't worry folks we're going to edit
this part out yet don't pet pet didn't
say anything about a Keurig okay we're
giving away three bags of coffee only
open to us customers international
shipping is extra and to get you
something that's perishable like coffee
in a short period of time it's really
really expensive so this is open to us
customers you go to david pakman.com
slash free beans okay free beans all one
word david pakman.com slash free beans
with a yearly membership you will get a
free 12 ounce bag of david pakman show
coffee if you want the drip coffee you
can have that if you want the espresso
coffee you can have that you can also
choose your grind size if you grind your
own coffee you can get it whole bean if
you want it already free ground you can
select what kind of a coffee maker
you're using and we will send it to you
already ground again the coffee comes
from blue fire coffee roasters in
hopedale massachusetts
Patrick Maloney is doing a heck of a job
over there and I mean that seriously not
like when George W Bush said to Michael
Brown the head of FEMA that he was doing
a heck of a job brownie we actually have
a heck of a job being done by Patrick
Maloney over at blue fire coffee
roasters david pakman.com slash free
beans you get the membership we send you
a bag of coffee for free free shipping
of course within the United States not
combine able with other offers blah blah
blah all that stuff just do it though
that's really the message i guess for me
pat which is who doesn't like coffee
these days yeah i mean what's holding
you back at this point you get to enjoy
all the perks of membership and you get
to be hyped up while you do it yeah and
some people asking if there's plans for
a decaf roast at some point I'm not
against it I have no problem with decaf
I mean I don't drink caffeine after
after 3 30-4 p.m. but right now you know
it's enough enough work managing the 2
roasts that we there was going to be
another blend it would be decaffeinated
yes and there was somebody told me a
really funny name that we could have for
a decaf roast of I don't remember it oh
I think it was something like
Massachusetts Republican because some
people call Massachusetts Republican
sort of CAF Republican it's something
like that I'm butchering it but it was
something along those lines